تعمل الرافعات والآليات الثقيلة
في رمات شلومو في شرق القدس
منذ ما يقرب من 30 عامًا
بالنسبة لمعظم المجتمع الدولي ، حيث
تقف هذه المنازل الإسرائيلية على
أرض فلسطينية محتلة ، وبالتالي تعتبر
غير قانونية
، حيث تم تصنيف
أكثر من ألف منزل جديد
تمت الموافقة على البناء هنا في
الوقت الذي كان فيه جو بايدن يقوم بزيارته الأولى
كنائب للرئيس ،
فقد كان ينظر إليه على أنه صفعة على الوجه
بالأمس ، فإن قرار الحكومة
الإسرائيلية بالتخطيط المسبق لوحدات سكنية جديدة
في القدس الشرقية
يقوض
تلك الثقة التي نتمتع بها.  تحتاج الآن
من أجل البدء وكذلك
إنتاج مفاوضات مربحة ،
ولكن ما إذا كان البيت الأبيض قد أحب ذلك أم
لا ، فإن الخطط تتحرك إلى الأمام ،
تعيش هانا توليدانو في أحد الشوارع الجديدة التي تم
الإعلان عنها منذ 12 عامًا والتي تم
تسميتها باسم جدها ،
فهذا طريقي.  أنا هانا توليدانو ، هل
تشعر أن هذه الأرض ملكك
هذه الأرض لك ،
أعتقد أن هذه الأرض هي أرضنا وليست
أرضنا  إنها تنتمي لليهود ،
فلا شك في وجود قوة
للشعور بالأرض هنا والمطالبات المختلفة
عليها
بمجرد أن تسعى الولايات المتحدة إلى قيادة
جهود السلام هنا والتأثير على السياسة ،
لكن تأثيرها كان محدودًا على الرغم من
الضغط الأمريكي
المستمر على الإسرائيليين.  إبطاء أو إيقاف
بناء المستوطنات كجزء من
إجراءات بناء الثقة مع الفلسطينيين ،
تظهر الحقائق على الأرض هنا في رمات
شلومو أن البناء والتوسع مستمران
في الواقع بشكل متزايد ، هناك شعور
بأنه حتى لو أراد الرئيس الأمريكي بايدن
الحصول على
قليل من هنا سيولي الكثير من الاهتمام ،
إنه ليس مجرد شخصية لأنه
قد يكون لديه معرفة بأنه قد يكون لديه
أفكار أخرى أو أي شيء لا يمتلكه هو
الشخصية التي لا نقولها
لهم اليوم كيف يبنون في بلدهم
لا أحد يستطيع  ليقول لنا كيف نبني في بلدنا
على بعد بضع عشرات من الكيلومترات تقع
مدينة بيت لحم الفلسطينية في
الضفة الغربية
هنا ، سيقرر الرئيس  تجد صعوبة في
تجنب التذكير الصارخ بالصراع ،
إحدى القضايا التي من المحتمل أن
تقود الرئيس بايدن في مواجهة
مقتل شيرين أبو عكلي ، هذه
اللوحة الجدارية العملاقة لصحفي الجزيرة
على الطريق الذي تسلكه عند دخولك
بيت لحم
بالنسبة للكثيرين.  هنا كان رد الولايات المتحدة على
مقتل المراسل الأمريكي الفلسطيني
بالرصاص أثناء تغطيته
لعملية عسكرية إسرائيلية
غير
كافٍ ، آخرها في قائمة متزايدة من
خيبات الأمل في إدارة بايدن ،
آمل أن أحظى ببعض الفرصة ولكن لأكون
صادقًا معك  ليس لدي أمل في
الحصول على أي شيء جيد من زيارته في
فلسطين أو في أي مكان في الشرق الأوسط
حتى هذه هي الأرض المقدسة
ونحات الخشب سمير لولا يأمل أن تزود زيارة بايدن
المخططة لكنيسة
المهد الشرارة الروحية التي
يحتاجها المؤمنون.
رئيس كاثوليكي يزور مسقط رأس يسوع
ونذكره أنه حتى يسوع يقول الحب
لا يسقط أبدًا ، هذا ما نريد السلام
الذي سيحققه.  حب لنا ولكل
منا
وميض نادر من التفاؤل بشأن قضية
يعتقد معظمنا هنا أن البيت الأبيض
يفضل تنحية